[Music]
one more
time hello hello and welcome back to the
break room this is our daily live show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news that you need to know coming up on
the show today we have our she-hulk
fantasies and you're gonna love to hear
them uh also is boba fett season two
frozen in carbonite who will save us
that's no moon hey and who out there has
got beef with titania
titanium
i refuse to say that i will not have
that clip of me saying that existing on
the internet well you could check me
saying titiana on all four cameras
that's right you can check him right
there he's tommy bechto hey
hi everyone
good to be here
and also good to be here it's jessica
clements i pronounce it titiana
that's the correct way i said it real
fast but i wasn't on camera so they
can't clip it
all right
and you know what we're doing some
redemptions today uh after every hundred
dollars in super chats uh that you guys
send in today we're gonna deliver our
closing arguments in honor of she-hulk
uh we have our own bucket of litigation
here uh inside this bucket some classic
uh uh this versus that yeah and uh for
every hundred dollars we'll draw one out
of the bucket and we'll give our closing
arguments we'll really bring it home
versus chevy yeah uh uh
fish versus snails
brandon versus jessica what what what
physical for physical fighting we're
gonna fight if we physically don't fight
brody stevens for life in the chat
strawberry dad yes brody hate one eight
till i die enjoy it
yes enjoy and enjoy this video by
hitting that like button if you're out
there watching right now we sure do
appreciate it uh also check out our
discord if you're 18 years or older new
rockstars is on discord you can go on
there you can have fun conversations
with fun people you can also submit a
clip of the week of the break room oh
yeah you can send in a voicemail you can
do all sorts of stuff check that out uh
but before you check that out
check out these headlines oh well yeah i
really dove forward in my seat
i always went tumbling
for the the three of you out there that
still have those 3d televisions that
were so popular
uh you really enjoyed that damn yeah
that was a flop
i never
i remember my friend had one growing up
and i thought it was the coolest thing
in the world but now you just brought it
up and i forgot they existed i think
it's cool you had a friend growing up oh
oh come on all i had were my twigs but i
made it to dolls oh
speaking of twig fan dolls at fan expo
in boston
ming na wen was asked if she was excited
for any upcoming projects and this was
her answer she said quote second season
of the book of boba fett i hope
i hope
uh help me disney executives you're our
only help you gotta make another season
of it uh she said i never count my
chickens before they hatch because in
this business you just never know baby
but knock on wood they'll be announcing
that soon liar liar pants on fire she
knows they're making a season oh okay
and she was covering her ass with all
that boilerplate
oh i don't know if it's happening yeah
she's like wow
well it's not it's not fully it's not
the same thing but she was in uh
mandalorian wasn't yeah yeah yeah so
it's like she's still gonna show up
probably amanda show up d23 which break
room will have a presence at you best
believe yeah we're credentialed
we're hunky we're ready to go yeah uh
they're gonna be announcing poca boba
fett season two i'm predicting it right
now yeah they're gonna have a big star
wars day or a panel there i'm sure
they'll make some announcements what
would the book of boba fett second
season even look like what happens more
mods baby more it's more uh more metal
all i know is i hope it's just another
eight episodes on tatooine god i can't
get enough and we gotta get danny back
as the rancor trader we do i i what i
would hope for a season two would be
like all right uh i've fixed every
problem on tatooine the mods gotta i
gotta get it they got a cool fighter
club i'm just gonna sail around the the
galaxy i'm gonna sedate my rancor put
him on a ship yeah yeah and take it off
around maybe
yeah go to a different planet with a
different climate please i'm begging you
yeah uh
uh next headline um speaking as a guest
on the comedy bang bang podcast with
scott ackerman she hope lead star
tatiana maslany revealed that she almost
played another marvel character yeah
prior to her mcu no kidding okay you
know who i think it might have probably
been who do you think about actually no
i take this back i take this back
because i'll say i think she would end
up playing like
she has to be like a best friend i think
she would have been a best friend she
didn't take that role and now she's
further and she's i could see her being
elena elena wow
i you know what i recently singled
florence pio yeah well either elena or i
could see her uh being one of the black
like one of the women that were there
maybe the first woman that i came out of
my weirdo
i mean she would be good elena based on
her work in orphan black right she was
like incredible that was my thought yeah
uh but in this conversation it was
revealed that
maslany wanted to play wanted to play
michelle williams role as annie wang uh
aka wayne how do you say that weighing
annie wayne aka she venom for two
minutes and 35 seconds yeah uh and
thankfully so she really wanted that
role yeah and they passed on her they
said no they said no we lost out they
said we lucked out we did i think she
left
there i think she lucked out because
also annie um uh and he doesn't have
that much screen not as much screen time
as i want i want to see when we put her
in the venom costume i was so stoked
that it was gone so i was like it was
gone so fast yeah i was like no give her
a real venom yeah give her a real suit i
want to be on the woman to get
let's get another venom movie out there
guys come on it's been two hours right
now he's already right
it's tom hardy's passion i think tom
hardy gets in like uh one of those uh
self-doubt uh
self-deprecating
i need a self-deprecation i'm so fat i
can barely fit in this
uh it just echoes your own life hitting
thoughts at yourself oh my gosh what a
nightmare uh yeah thank you for passing
on
uh tatiana yeah you're looking good yeah
i like her being a more prominent lead
character absolutely uh next headline
she-hulk showrunner jessica gao told
variety that she hold attorney at law
was not the first time she pitched
jennifer walters in a storyline she
actually pitched her as a character in
the black widow movie but was told by
marvel execs that she was pitching a
this black widow movie as quote a
she-hulk movie with black widow in it
correct me if i'm wrong but i think we
covered a story earlier in the week
where she also was trying to include it
in another movie or another tv show yeah
she basically said she's been trying to
get she-hulk yeah everything she
submitted to marvel over the years
involved she-hulk do you think they were
like we're like okay jessica you're
gonna do this this is how i picture it
okay jessica you're gonna do she-hulk
and then she's watching all her
colleagues from like rick and morty's
show's already getting started and she's
like i've been waiting six years
you guys have not put me in anything and
i keep pitching ways we can do this do
you think
what a great pipeline that is rick and
morty to the marvel cinematic universe
well there's an okay so yeah we have the
guy loveness
jeff loved him yeah yes yes who it was
uh kimmel writer to rick and morty to
ant-man quantum mania yes we have
michael waldron michael who's doing
everything now we have jessica
the russo
came from community yeah oh yeah they
did
a couple episodes
so really dan harmon is like the secret
mastermind behind me he's out there john
hartman keeps saying no
kevin feige he's like please and he's
like no stop asking him
brandon's good friend dan good friend
good friend to this child
i've known dan harmon
i've interacted with him if we passed on
the street again would he remember me i
hope so i think i think a twinkle in his
eye i think he likes you yeah yeah i'll
tell you about it was a brief period of
my life it was exciting it was thrilling
yeah uh
in another interview and our next
headline uh but i will before we move on
headlines actually i do want to say
kudos to marvel like jessica clearly
wanted to tell a yes a she-hulk story
and they let her have the movie instead
of like denying her the thing she wants
to do i think that that gives me a lot
of hope for this show that it's going to
be great because like this she's been
working on it there's a passionate story
to tell about this character and really
likes this character
and isn't like oh yeah they gave me the
movie and i read the comics for the last
three months and i'm ready to go really
like manifest what you want to work on
and maybe it will happen yeah hellcat
hellcat
give me hellcat
i like that do you want her too yeah
with you all right okay officially now
next headline in another interview uh
this time with comicbook.com jessica gao
said she was most inspired by john burns
she hold comic book run adding quote it
was what made me fall in love with the
character in the first place i wish i
had an image of what which one this was
because i i've read them all you've read
them all yeah this one is the brand one
i don't know talk think about it the
newest one
if you guys you know if you don't call
into the show please john just let me
know the year
ping me if you know uh go ahead and hit
me on my uh instagram uh and maybe if
you know send it in a little tiny super
chat we've already been getting some
super chats thanks to our super chatters
out there yeah graveyard always
showing up for us yes graveyard did
someone say depravity also number one
reason for strike down bears beers and
bears beards
yeah that's the one that's the one
okay and also thanks to tony kevin i
have to wait to watch until after work
but wanted to quickly send a super chat
you three rule hey
tony tony uh and you can rule to
whoever you are out there your breakers
your room we send in a super chat we're
gonna be doing our closing arguments
yeah you wanna see us get all the kids
on each other yeah you wanna see what we
got before she-hulk shows what she got
check it out i want to see what she got
we do have the hulk microphone back so
maybe yeah the hulk microphone you might
hulk out we may honk out the whole man
uh another at the premiere of she-hulk
uh jameel jamel had a lot to say about
her future in the mcu this is what i get
i like to see this you call your shots
yeah you call your shots she said quote
i want to drive deadpool crazy i love
ryan reynolds i love deadpool so much
there's so much for the mcu the
thunderbolts there's so many places that
titania can exist in the mcu because
she's so messy and vile she's pissed off
most of the mcu spider-man thor she's
got enemies everywhere kind of like me
in real life yeah that's a real talk
real talk yeah
yeah i i love this idea that she's like
creating her own mcu canon like whatever
i say has to go and now they have to
like work it in absolutely that's a
titania behavior also
in a very legal sense you know the
burden of proof is on them now she's put
it on
them not in the mcu already and and and
also self-awareness on jameel's uh uh
part of knowing i mean she got dragged
when she was named host of that uh
um uh ball ballroom show on hbo max she
got dragged for uh
ripping the kardashians and everyone who
promoted weight loss teas and other
things she spoke up on behalf of the
common man she's not afraid to speak up
yeah i like her i'm into it she says
what she wants uh on social media and so
i'm wondering if her character is going
to be the same way maybe talking
[ __ ] about like thor or spiderman yeah
or spider-man he's just a teenager but
the kids don't know that anymore they
don't know where he is they're with
their brains yeah they scrambled our
brains someone's gotta do something
about these wizards
too many sorcerers too many sorcerers uh
and also at the premiere uh the original
hulk mark ruffalo said uh quote no she's
she's she-hulk in now there's not going
to be another event oh sorry i screwed
this headlight up uh basically mark
ruffalo was saying that she-hulk would
be in the avengers yeah
like the fact that she exists means she
should be in the event right not him not
him or he could be maybe both
basically saying like whatever the next
iterations of the avengers are she's not
getting left out she's gonna be out
she'll be there yeah she's showing up i
think she's gonna well it depends on how
we're gonna see her end the season but i
think she's gonna be the leader of some
team soon
um because she deserves it i like it
also they always make the leader of the
team someone that's like strong that
doesn't have like the physical like
actual super powers like wanda wasn't
the leader but they made captain america
uh she-hulk is usually like the leader
after uh secret wars and it's just
because she's like logical and also just
she doesn't she's not like yeah i can i
have all these superpowers i deserve to
be she's just like i'm just strong but i
am smart
and i love her
i love her oh oh it's my turn sorry i
was like wow so quiet it's my turn it's
our discussion you guys the break room
is getting into the fantasy sports game
with our fantasy she-hulk league yeah
we're gonna have you follow along with
us every week as we complete uh compete
to see who can most accurately predict
what's going to happen in the show uh we
have a list right here in front of us of
all of our predictions and then you guys
can just choose who you back or you can
also put in your two cents about like
why our backings are so ridiculous but
at the end of all of this the winner
doesn't really get their face on the
wall behind the wall of champions the
world of champions they also get to
choose whatever dinner they want i
already chose the seafood boil
do you get the dinner on the show i
would i would
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah
we'll get that they're not shooting that
anymore so yeah we're gonna do these
fantasy pics yes we'll do them every
episode uh if you don't know she-hulk
premieres tonight at midnight on disney
plus uh you know write down your own
predictions at home yeah
so we start with our pre-season picks
our five-round drafts we made picks for
the whole season long and then we're
also doing weekly picks okay so the
first one round one and two mca mcu mcu
cameo yeah who is our mcu cameo
oh oh i picked grand master okay cameo
and i also picked ghost rider not johnny
blaze flaming skull ghost writer no
casting of johnny blaise
where is the ghost right are gonna come
in just showing up to be like showing up
i don't like you using my name yeah to
show up to don these are cameos that we
think happen on the show
we've obviously seen some in the
trailer yeah yeah we're we're avoiding
those these are these
which is why i chose jessica jones
because i think at the end of the series
jessica jones when she at the end of the
series when she gets her own office
she's going to go to new york get her
own office and it's going to be right
next to jessica jones's office and also
i put cassie lange because we know
cassie's gonna start aqua uh aquaman uh
we're she's gonna start ant-man like in
prison she has like a jail background
and i think this would be a great way
for amanda it does connect and generally
help me i like that i like that here
here are my picks for cameos okay yeah
first pick is gonna be maria hill okay
okay we're getting close to secret
invasion i think they want to start
tying in that we haven't seen maria for
quite some time not since we saw fake
maria hill uh in spider-man far from
home i was re-watching some old mcu she
was a big deal she was in a lot of stuff
appeared a lot and up to up to and after
the first avengers even had a big
presence in uh for uh winter soldier i
think maria hill is my first one my
second one yep this is kind of close to
yours i think we're gonna see scott oh
ant-man
scott lang talk and i think he's running
his mouth too much i think it might get
him in oh right because he's doing the
podcast yeah yeah i think paul rudd
might might make a cameo on this show i
love you guys let us know which one of
you guys we also we should mention sorry
i you know i love cutting off jessica we
should also mention uh
zach erica wusu
john and uh koi
have also made pictures yeah we've been
getting picked and who
and ann uh
we have a bunch of people on the new
rockstars uh staff and friends of the
show so we'll let everybody get our
picks out there guys
someone says karen page and foggy nelson
which i was debating on we know
karen page's um
husband in real life is a guy who did
improv with us ej and he said
on instagram that she's not in this show
he said i wish she was so either he's a
liar hello he might be live
but he didn't claim she's not in the
show we don't know if he tweeted that
yeah we don't know
he put it
major character death yeah major
character death you want to go first you
want me to go you go so this is a major
character dies on the show dies on the
show i said nicky her best friend
because it ain't a show unless either
her parents have to die or best friend
guys and we are gonzaga
yes we've seen too much of the friend
and i also think the friend is kind of
underlying playing jill stevens from
like the comic book who dies in the car
collection
mm-hmm sorry
are they gonna refrigerator is that
what's happening
are you doing daredevil season three put
her in the freezer
the friends you want to kill the kids in
stranger things yeah well they had it
coming yeah those kids deserve to die in
real life move out of the town move out
of hopkins it's a problem yeah come on
you stay there that's your fault that's
that's on you uh i said
pug
oh
josh
who i love uh he's gonna die he's gonna
sacrifice himself
here's my pick and i'm picking this
based on some news we heard that this
guy kind of ran his mouth a little uh
about his character yeah uh he plays
todd
you know they kind of compared him to
like uh tony stark wannabe yeah i think
he's i think he's going to be up to no
good this todd character uh and i think
he might turn out to be a secret like
antagonist i like to say todd he's
played by the actor john john bass yeah
funny guy very funny guy yeah very funny
guy he's gonna be on the show what what
he's playing
i think i think he initially goes on a
date
oh
jennifer now we're 21 away
from
settling a lifelong debate
arguments legal legal problems that's
right we are getting great super chats
though quintin said in a superchat and
he said i hope barton and jess get to
interact oh yeah he's maybe calling a
little clint barton uh
uh a cameo
which would be good that would be a good
one are we aware after well no because
this takes place a little bit after
shang chi which is not
um
before hawkeye before hawkeye or no no
no it's aft no it's before it's before
it's way before
he's just retired right now yeah but no
one knows that he's he's ronin he's
chilling no one else he's getting
comments i need to interact
you guys for our uh round four we have
the catch phrase what's the catchphrase
of the season going to look like oh i
said you wouldn't like me when i'm
hungry
is is she-hulk saying it yeah okay i
said it's she-hulk but i didn't mean it
like as in like it's she-hulk it's like
people are going to be like oh it's girl
hulk or oh it's lady green and she's
going to say it's correcting them yeah i
like it i like that okay this is mine
and this isn't she-hulk saying this okay
i just want to clarify okay this is
bruce saying this to she-hulk he says
like she-hulk smash oh she gives them a
look she gives them a look like that's
not cool oh cousin that's not funny okay
that's lame cousin but he's gonna give a
bear with you guys
come on closer for round five we have
the freestyle prediction which is just a
crazy prediction
in the in the season right okay anything
in the season i said she hold goes this
a car oh okay i think she's gonna go to
the car uh i also
this is kind of based on the car we saw
the sicarian ship in the in the previews
i think and we were talking about this
away yesterday i think it's gonna be
revealed that hulk has this gonna be on
this in this season it will reveal that
has his son he sired during his hulk
record it's got to be
i believe uh my prediction goes back to
todd our aforementioned tie okay you
know he's a tony stark wannabe i believe
he is going to make a
uh prototype iron man suit of his own
that will cause him to be gravely
injured in an effort to impress she-hulk
he's going to come in and be like i'm
bringing the party to you and then get
ripped in half okay yeah i like that oh
yeah perfect yeah for and then we have
our weekly draft you guys yes our round
one the she-hulk trial reason
so so this like our first episode that
drops tonight tomorrow we will say okay
what was the trial reason what's the
reason that jennifer walters is in court
yes got it right yes she's gonna be inc
we think she's gonna be in court this
first episode what's the reason she'll
be in court
i think she's going to be assigned as a
public defender
to
someone sh crappy about okay yeah okay i
said she's representing herself oh like
she's not driving yeah she's not joking
how could it be like a little
uh
beginning at the end yeah
like the end we're doing is gonna be
okay we're doing a quinn tarantino a
little bit in media
probably cinephiles out there where are
you going cinephiles uh i think we're
going to see her in court
uh but it's going to be as like a second
co-counsel yeah she's going to be
co-counsel frustrated sitting at the
desk they're not letting her talk and
they're letting like some douchebag
lawyer talk and he's screwing it up and
she's gonna be like i should be up there
got it and that's gonna lead to her
getting fired because she's gonna talk
she's gonna complain and they're gonna
fire her unjustly i like it i uh oh and
then we got a round two did you do yours
i did oh yeah yeah no you were the
defender
around two is our action sequence what
action sequence will we see in the first
episode um i said she throws a surfboard
at hulk and i say that
and they're going to get in a fight and
she's going to throw either that or a
beach ball at them i like that a beach
ball to the face can be more devastating
than you'd think i said uh
a very sedated calm emil blonsky is
going to suddenly abomination out like
he's going to be like sitting there like
well here's the thing
and then just break down yeah okay okay
i said that i think hulk and she-hulk
will get into a fight like a physical oh
yeah
i don't think it'll necessarily be mean
like they're not they don't hate each
other okay i think maybe for training
purposes but we'll see like a good fight
between the two of them the first
episode and in our first episode what is
the most random prediction we can we
we're going to get what is the most
random and i'll be honest what happened
in this episode yeah i kind of i did a
blanket one okay i did a blanket one i
said we're gonna get a glimpse of stark
tools she did put tools in in quote
i
industry
marks
i okay first of all you know dan wadden
type this he's out john typed things out
and that was true
penis
that was john sporting
we're blaming
my random prediction for the first
episode we we saw like in the early
photo got released of like jennifer and
bruce like back to back and it looked
like an 80s
drama yeah yeah we're gonna see that
commercial in the first episode so funny
some sort of like ally mcbeal one
division
weird vision thing we're gonna see that
that that commercial in the future i
like that that's gonna
maybe bring back commercial man and
woman oh yeah i said because i think
they made such a huge deal of it at the
end of ms marvel
we're going to hear that x-men stinger
again we're going to get that banana oh
in the first episode yeah okay i think
they're going to
jump right into the music
we have we have some more predictions to
get through real fast but we did go over
our
chat redemption oh jessica you get to
give a closing argument i think you
should give it before we get deeper into
our yeah so i grab one of these you're
going to grab one of these it's going to
be a classic this or that and you're
going to you're going to pick one side
and i'm going to pick one side yeah yeah
yeah
what did you get
i'll say it in the middle oh okay i'm
going to reveal what it is oh wow okay
so these are your closing arguments you
were def you're you're going for one
side in this argument
ladies and gentlemen of the jury oh my
god beautiful boys in this room oh my
god
i'm gonna tell you why
i'm gonna tell you why
hamburgers are better than hot dogs
i'm a hot dog man i don't know i'm gonna
persuade you with hamburgers and hot
dogs you guys we don't know what's in
this hot dog oh we don't know what
pieces they made to make this hot dog
there is some pig in there your life
gets shorter yes yes yes your life's
shortened if you eat this hot dog that
is true i didn't read that and let me
tell you
do you when you go to red robin do you
get the hot dog i've never been to a red
robe
robin do you get the hot dogs
sir when you go to jack-in-the-box do
you get the hot dog i've never been to a
jack-in-the-box in my life that's not
true that's poor people food
when you when you go to masters do you
get the hot dog i don't i don't i get
the chicken parmesan oh chicken parmesan
okay and i get extra bread hey extra
person extra bread
that supposed to interrupt the
chocolate
over
extra bread you can get that in a
hamburger oh
have you ever heard of a quadruple mac
from burger king no no because that
doesn't exist no well you said you
didn't even go
uh objection this woman is clearly no no
what i'm saying
is yeah we could go to a butcher's shop
and get the finest slab of beef put it
on a bun with pickles and check out the
hotel the break room you get to find a
slab of beef if you want it's me you
know what i'm saying it's a mirror
if you want a tall glass of water a nice
fine hamburger wow slab of beef served
up straight to your door you're going to
choose hamburger that's right but if you
want a weenie
a poor man's weenie oh come on oh no
roast piece of flabby weenie when you go
for the hot dog you go for it and also
i get confused between if a glizzy is a
hot dog or a knot i believe it is a hot
dog i thought it was a gun if you were
born uh after the year 2000 and you're
in the chat let us know what a glitch i
think lizzie is like a widget it can
mean anything so that's wrong all in all
judge
jury and executioner whoa the
executioner's here this is why i stand
for hamburgers and i think you guys can
agree with me vegetarian or not
hamburgers are the way to go let me get
some glizzies in the chat
welcome to the good burger home of the
good burger can i have your order wow
wow
carl's jr did have a fourth of july
burger that was
a hamburger a hot dog and potato chips i
believe well that's beautiful and i
believe a girl we improvised with was in
that commercial that's beautiful yeah uh
should we do our over on those real
quick yeah yeah yeah yeah let's repair
these predictions yeah uh okay so
do you sorry i didn't know you go here
you go no you've got to all right let's
do our finders here okay this is for the
whole season these are for the yeah yeah
over unders total number of cases that
we see jennifer try in court and there's
an appearance of trying a case 4.5 yeah
over under on that i took you over you
took the over i took the over you took
the over i'm
i don't think they're going to show that
many court cases you think we're getting
out of the litigation i don't think it's
going to be as much
it's going to be montagey you're going
to get like six cases in one episode i
don't think so um i'll take the under uh
total number of love interests wow and
this isn't like how many times she get
down she can do as much she wants uh
sure this is like i think potential
characters that could legitimately
potentially become
love interests yeah not just like date
montage okay when we when we okay so
when we talked about this i thought we
said that it's people that she gets down
yes
but not people that she just goes on
dates with not just girls but people she
either does get down with or could so if
you're adding up fall in love with come
back second season don't wanna be that
present but i see a lot of hamburgers in
the chat y'all with me now
you say burger ham burger ham burger all
right hamburg oh i see there was one hot
dog in there thank goodness
frederick so this is proctor you've
changed that odd dog right now so this
is totally remember
total number of love interests 3.5 3.5 i
said under i said under because i think
she's gonna okay good okay then we're
all right these are gonna set up like
three potentials but not four i think
it's going to be pug
todd
and uh another hand
i think she's gonna if she runs one more
than four
that thing do foreign that thing down
well speaking of that thing okay
speaking about about that
okay
uh total number of confirmed bone
sessions and if you're watching with
your children at home i apologize i
don't write this agree all right total
number of confirmed
bones i'm the only person 1.5 1.5 is is
is the number i'm the only person that
said under i went over i went over just
because you guys want to go over
just because you guys want to have
something like this episodes in which
matt murdock and this is for the entire
season yes episodes in which matt
murdock or the daredevil appear well i
was this is 2.5
i was the only one i went over everyone
else went under it tasteful you tommy
tommy spoiled it you guys said it so we
won that one over and we went on dirt oh
sorry yes i ruined the suspension
uh i just was this is fantastic i was
surprised nobody uh i think in a show of
nine episodes yes yeah i don't think we
get more than two and a half episodes i
think he's gonna show up in two episodes
just two because there's so much other
stuff going on and it's only gonna be
for advice well i hope he shows up for
three i mean they they have been trying
to inflate our expectations a little bit
which i think is gutsy on their behalf
uh you know what else is gutsy send it
in those super chats baby yeah
some good ones let's read some uh ben
missouri said uh has an appearance by
leader been hinted or confirmed he could
be the hidden big bad i know our boy mt
wants to see leo come back i would love
to see uh leader come back
i think he has to come back only because
it's like how are you going to bring
back abomination yeah but you're not
going to bring back the light i mean
he's a great we kind of had this
conversation yesterday about world war
hulk but yeah coming back for that i
think if he was in the comics it was
hinted that he was taken by hydra i
believe there was like a comic based on
fury's big week and that was one of the
things that happened during that week
and i think if i remember correctly
natasha says that hydra took him
something like that i don't know i've
totally forgotten hey if i'm wrong uh
put it in the chat and then don't i
think we'll see him eventually
especially if they're like saying that
we're going to get more folks it's like
variations and this is about
quentin sent in a super chat saying hot
dog was a catchphrase back in the day
hot dog sand hot dog dog diggity dog
mcmuffin
yeah
who's clubhouse mickey mouse
uh runaway dad and forces hulk to
release rage to fight him and that's how
we get into seeing a nerf talk trash
bags yes cory's in the biz so he does
know what he's talking about uh i i
split him up he had two
i messed up corey i'm sorry this is what
corey said just piggybacking off
yesterday but they say time works
differently onto the car so what if star
shows up full grown looking for his
runaway
holy cannoli yeah keep saying those
super chats let's do some more closing
arguments yeah uh but first tommy i
think we should thank our sponsors yes
let's shout out our friends at the epic
hero shop they just released the green
justice merch line inspired by
the lady that we're all talking about
she hulk it's got several different
t-shirt designs including the newest
limited edition latest obsession shirt
lady justice and
if you buy this uh shirt if you buy our
latest obsession shirt you unlock the
opportunity to give a custom shout out
read by one of our
marvel hosts including
the breakdown
goddess herself jessica clement that's
right jessica clements gonna be breaking
down every step episode of she-hulk on
my channel she's gonna be on inside
marvel during the she-hulk run yeah oh
my god
we're very excited they're also going to
be dropping lines inspired by house of
the dragon
andor and rings of power in the coming
weeks we're very excited for that so
much more merch drops to come and those
nine
shirts they are limited edition yeah so
get yours before the world collapses
yes yeah for the people in the chat
because some of you guys have been
asking i don't know for the time minute
from right now but she hold drops
tonight midnight
west coast time yeah 3 a.m for those on
these yeah 3 a.m for y'all and that's
what we think that's what traditionally
disney plus does they do a midnight
pacific release yeah uh for their show
so maybe those have read our
expectations maybe they'll put it out at
five but you know what's gonna happen
right now what's gonna happen right now
mandatory fun
you thought we were gonna forget about
it we were
just breathing just breathing like a
lizzy and the wind yes this is where i
gather my two best friends in the whole
world and i force them to have fun with
me now yesterday was my dear nephew
ashton's birthday oh happy birthday
birthday god damn i wish him
a happy birthday but it's because he
betrayed me
and became a toronto blue jays fan but
everyone knows respect those are tigers
people oh so happy birthday ashton
or should i say trashton the first trash
bag my favorite trash bag i love you
buddy now
mandatory fun play the graphic again
clean slate
after that and then wait i need to do a
happy birthday shout out
happy birthday give me a camera for you
happy birthday to donnie wahlberg um
people look at you as the lesser
wahlberg but not me
that's it that's in sixth sense i
thought he was would you like that face
i didn't think you were what did you
listen to your wall i don't think you
should put that out there i mean we all
know that lester wahlberg is that third
brother that runs the restaurant that
looks like a little the number one one
what's his name wally wahlberg anyway
you're putting mark three uh mark three
absolutely mark three mark wahlberg's a
poser
come on the show and fight me five foot
five hobbit do it now
we all know bruce banner is accidentally
at fault for making jennifer walters
it's his fault he bled into it now i've
gotten in some hairy situations with
fluid exchanges so i'm not judging you
ever but into a cousin yeah all the time
i put into all my cousins blood and
blood out that's how you get in the gang
i don't like hearing that's how you
become a tiger's fan so yeah that's
right that's how you go to detroit you
bleed into your cousin now
so bruce is responsible for
inadvertently turning his cousin into a
superhero she-hulk who we all know is
incredible but for mandatory fun today
we're thinking what are some other
superheroes that can accidentally turn
their cousins into heroes that might be
a little less impressive oh okay yeah so
i want you guys to think that they love
a cousin hero yeah an existing hero who
has a weird cousin okay but they turn it
into something
okay so mine is
here's mine yeah it's my hero my first
hero is the flash oh boy okay okay and
he's got a cousin holding my breath here
and uh when you know he was running
around his cousin and he put some of the
speed force into the country but only
into the cousin's bowels okay just a
little bit of the speed force straight
into the bowels
and now
his cousin is wow the flush and he's the
flush he can both urinate and defecate i
love that any speed he wants
so like he can ask to use your restroom
you can say no but by then he's already
gone he's already done it now you can't
run fast any other time only when it's
running into the bathroom using the
toilet oh running out all the excretion
like he's he's too fast even for
uh the sensor to pick up that he was
even there right sometimes the flush
doesn't even happen my flush is so fast
oh my god but that it's only with
defecation and urination nothing else
yeah no why else is that normal do you
want that life oh i would love that one
i like we got a chat that says uh
mercy williams said okay pause
okay she needs a break from whatever the
flush was i love it i'm a big fan of the
front i love the flies what do you got
for me jessica um
my uh did you guys know
that um uh harley quinn has a cousin wow
no i didn't know oh okay uh his name is
type five type five five why is he
harley quinn you know i'm not digging
into this too much
let's pause
you go
let's go it's type five five i love type
five
he walks around with a microphone
and he's constantly just trying to
practice material
stand up and stand up that he's never
invited to i absolutely love that that's
somehow harley quinn's cousin and not
the joker's cousin yeah well
it was when they were married
a lot of people pointing out my hair
should have been the runs which is also
big the runs is great but the flush
i was going for the uh the accidents
there of this the similar sounding my
name is terry allen and i defend this
city
star labs they're just like god every
bathroom at star labs is destroyed what
happened what happened looks like
someone exploded
yeah my guy is he's pretty basic he's uh
reed richards mr fantastics cousin uh
his name is creed richards
and his name is mr mediocre mystery yeah
i feel like this is pointed and all that
happens is creed richard's like he goes
like this stretch and like he just gets
like limp little like salad fingers he's
like
salad fingers he just gets long fingers
yeah just all he can make is his fingers
long and they just flop they just go out
like little tentacles and he just waves
them around he can wash cars with him
that's about it he can dry his car off
if it's raining i love it i want more
can we do another round yes do another
round
tim tim the seven one six point out uh
tight vibes should be farley quinn oh
my name is matt foley i am thrice
divorce that is a good one oh man we
love him uh all right do it again i want
to do another one you're good at improv
oh thanks uh wait you said we should do
another round and then you made another
person
you got to go first
you asked for another round encouraging
it um
okay
so we got um
scarecrow
it would have been a funnier one if you
guys
that was that was very
concerning uh brandon you got another
one for me oh so you get time i like it
this is mandatory fun play my graphic
so we all know scott summers has a
brother of course he becomes hamlet but
he also has a cousin oh wow
uh and his cousin becomes cyprops oh no
cyclops instead of uh a normal anus his
anus opens a portal
to the poop dimension oh wow so when he
poops it's not actually his poop it's
poop from another dimension
we actually don't know where cyclops
this poop goes wow
that's incredible i think that's a good
one i wish i had that time to come up
with you when you guys hear about this
we all know nightcrawler aka kurt vogman
yeah
well do you guys know about bert wagner
aka day sprinter
[Music]
he's a he's a blue little busybody that
runs around gossiping but he teleports
and he's like i heard a rumor and then
he runs and goes over to someone but
rumor has it and then he goes to another
person and every time he tells a little
snitch lie he cuts the thing and he
gives himself attention
he does give himself a little tattoo oh
my god i love nightcrawler physical you
were like nightcrawler versus day
sprinter yep he's a real he's a real day
sprinter i gotta go tommy's gotta give a
closing argument i believe time for me
to give a closing argument we're gonna
close this yes thank you to all our
super chatters uh and if you have
questions or theories about uh uh
she-hulk episode one start throwing
those in now uh we'll we're gonna go
through our super chats we're gonna talk
about your questions uh and end prepping
for for uh uh some she-hulk episode one
but first tommy's gotta give a closing
ladies and gentlemen of the german oh my
gosh he's pacing i've been
lucky to be a citizen
in this great city of los angeles for 15
years
and i have never oh in my life
seen such an atrocious display of
misjustice until today yeah oh we're
trying to decide here which is better
cake or pie oh this is a good debate and
i want to argue with you right now that
it was never a competition to begin with
it's always been cake cake
bequeathed pie what pie only exists we
well for a second super chats were up to
twelve hundred dollars
i lost my place
i only came about because of cake's
success oh pau's been writing cakes
coattails
for nearly 80 years oh my 80 years let
me tell you about a couple people
historically that have been cake men
okay albert einstein cake man mahatma
gandhi oh i think he did okay i don't
think he could yeah the archbishop
desmond tutu oh
love the cake love the cake let me tell
you some people that love pie
arthur shaw cross serial killer charles
manson leader of the man i don't think
that's fair an adolf hitler i love the
blueberry come on that's not fair that's
not fair they all drink water too now
let me ask you people of course i don't
hate those people though someone puts a
pie in front of you someone puts a cake
in front of you and you gotta say
yes this pie deserves to die and i hope
it burns in hell oh my god it's cake all
the way this is cake i can't agree with
this i'm a pie guy the thing is i'm a
pie oh my gosh the bucket of truth um
can you do one
we got to get more super chats before
before we're not gonna just we're not
gonna we're not gonna we're not gonna
never know we're getting some great
super chats out there today i want to
make sure we get to all yeah also i
noticed in the chat um and in the polls
my joke was type five
night five type five
and i realized that that was a niche
group for type 5 types of diabetes is
when you do so bad in your stand-up show
that they give you diabetes as a curse
they're like sorry you bombed uh you
can't you can't eat candy yes thanks to
all those super chatters out there for
setting all your best uh uh super chats
we did get a super chat from jackson
brody who yeah super chat saying mcu
basketball started actually
she's our starting point
i'm taking pang born off the off the top
penguin with his powers sure he's still
he's still able to walk i take pangborn
right there okay uh that's a good one
quicksilver if we start okay
i don't think he's i don't think he i
don't think he's got the shoe but he can
speed yeah
i'll take scott lang he was in prison he
can play a little ball you're a giant
man uh yeah you can get big and get
timey i i like him uh i'm gonna take
uh the scarlet witch because she'll just
make damn basketball's mine that was my
existence
actually jackson had a very similar
lineup to you he dm'd me his oh yeah he
was five on five it was very okay yeah
and then i didn't take vision because
you know the geometry i'm taking miss
marvel oh okay
i'm taking wilson fists
who can block
that too baby that too baby i'm only
taking new yorkers and this is horrible
okay so miss marvel i got wilson fisk um
oh my god i need to only take new
yorkers this is spider-man
i'll take spider-man i'll take
spider-man but i make him throw that
spider-man cap and bucky those are all
new yorkers that is true i wanted to i
wanted another girl on my team oh i want
another girl on my team and i was like
kate bishop not good she's a new yorker
see you she's a shark yeah with her
fingers i need someone like an alley-oop
what about you tommy who you guys i'm
taking 5 earth 838 ultron
wait that's a winner that's a winning
ticket
all they do is full court three points
yes
every time they never miss yeah it's
perfectly executed
we win 390 to whatever you [ __ ] get
uh
thank you
thank you jeremy strickland for your
super chat the
mj29997 yep uh gary stepson in a super
chat do you think there's a chance that
shanghai could appear uh on she-hulk i
mean we love it similar come on the
break room
come on the show
sema we're reaching out soon simul if
you're watching and i know you are
i'm sending you i'm sending you a
personal correspondence through the mail
oh be careful when you open it
don't wait they're going to use that
against you one day you're back told
too you know what i mean he's situated
in san francisco the show's taking place
in l.a absolutely okay i'll allow one
one west coaster on my basketball team
is showing cheat with those jordans oh
that's true you don't play in the
jordans you can't play the jordans i
played one game in jordan's in high
school and they broke you never played
you'll join them never
church
different shirts i had t-rex for five
years mcgrady makes a shoe someone said
baron's emo i'm not putting barriers in
there you know they don't play
basketball
kisses at the crowd if it was what's
with these pics if it was football a
hashtag american soccer yeah uh
i would pick brian zemo because he's
european he's playing in sokovia they're
not playing basketball oh my god maybe
they are i saw the hustle
i mean i was the bad team
oh sorry no i was like what was the uh
the people in uh uh falcon and winter
soldier the best oh the flags were gonna
take the flag smashers would take them
on my soft water plus
i would put them completely on my soccer
team
thanks for your super chat uh making
living good living well uh set in a
super chat what's dr strange up to while
wang is visiting jennifer walters
freezing the new york sanctum okay this
show is before we think it's before no
way home like the mind wipe stuff hasn't
happened yet so yeah he's hanging out
he's just wearing his harvard sweatshirt
yeah just being a jerk he's being a jerk
like wong is begging him to like do
something trying to give him orders he's
not respecting wong no he's like
buzz off fortify your mind he's like i
don't no i don't i don't want to do that
i won't back i got he's like i got
tickets to oklahoma i don't know you
know i got a date he's like i'm going to
see mine freak on broadway he's like
probably doing some perverse
some prefer spells to check in on
christine yeah oh my god yeah he's doing
a little very problematic behavior
curtis briggs i hate coming back to this
and i'm so sorry i should have put luke
cage on my team
luke cage replace captain america for me
because i think bucky can throw down
before captain america oh oh okay
america's ass off
he just got kicked
killed gregor sending the super chat for
the breakers thank you gregor oh gregor
gregor helter skelter
oh speaking of charles oh my god
charles manson i think it's hdx skeletor
but
i took it as help to sculptor i thought
the revolution was true
today
and it was
yes have you all seen the concept art of
love and thunder that was going to
include the gods that give juggernaut
his powers
because i'm not a [ __ ] loser okay
whoa trash bags trash bags just kidding
i'm joking i'm joking here your super
chat uh
omar austin asking what kane connection
comes from this series if any do we
think there'll be a kang why are we all
so desperate to connect
you want to see a photo of him yeah
i mean i want to connect
on a personal level but uh
uh i think oh there he goes pulling it
up i think
there's jonathan majors getting ready
for jihok i think he could show up it
would be interesting if a kang variant
showed up that was revealed later oh
yeah like if they mentioned a
businessman what if there is a lawyer
version variant that he's just like look
here you're going to meet a different
version of me soon that sucks wait all
the candy
once you get to a certain level of kang
miss you're you're aware of your king
nasty some people are kang's and they
don't know it so you're saying i might
be kidding but i just don't you don't
know it yet am i
nasty king uh if you're a ken yeah call
if you getting
in please the hot lines are open uh
chrissy's standing in a super chat
they're they are in civil courts she's
talking about the legal system here on
she-hulk they're in civil court not
criminal so there's no defendant or
prosecution both parties are plaintiffs
trying to determine liability oh okay uh
i fell asleep in in civics class so
thank you chris i uh actually won uh
district 10 intro to occupations future
business leaders of america title so i
know a bit about civil court oh okay
let's just say in the mock trial uh i
sentence everyone to death in my class
um
coming straight for me saying thought
kevin feige confirming captain america
is the virgin there's no captain what
kevin feige did do in a different
interview was confirmed that canonically
that he has hooked up with someone that
we've seen before oh
yeah i think i i've already tweeted
about this i'm angry about it i think
we're gonna learn more in the episode
but no way captain come on dude
basketball hoop in the office yeah we're
gonna get a full 10 foot basketball hoop
in the back
by setting it up no problem uh uh doubt
it happening but imagine the karaoke
session between kate from chongqi and
jennifer walters would have i think
they'd have a good character
yeah get out in there didn't they
already have a karaoke yeah
that's what she's saying but she's
saying like let's have one with yeah
yeah
uh and jen yeah and do and were they
saying fantasy from mike or what was
their song they were singing i don't
know oh i forgot it was like a popular
song if you know collins
michael is the end of the michael sykes
settling the goozy debate in our super
chat
they also call guns glizzies too there
was a hot dog first the term started in
dc glizzy
gobblers be going crazy out here
i don't know if i don't know how much
you're allowed to say that yeah
but thank you for the etymology of
glizzy much appreciated td jones our boy
as i think our boy i don't know d jones
what gender are you identify yourself
identify yourself my man on the inside
td uh lots of love for the flush in the
super chats cure of small bottle
obstructions everywhere uh and colin
oakman sent me a super chat i always
love to watch live thanks for all the
amazing content the break room always
here to get me through my weekly we do
our best we're here live every weekday
on hotel california
said cool and the king cool in the cave
okay i would love that uh but yes we're
live here every day on the break room
live from our very own break room here
at new rockstars headquarters be sure to
check out the discord yeah if you're 18
years old
just briefly what do you need to say
buddy
jessica for their
person that they're backing in terms of
oh i'm sorry
so for this first week we're doing
jessica's next week you can pick someone
new or you can continue to pick jessica
i see i came in dead last yeah yeah you
came in and dead last on those
predictions i mean we split the ticket
pretty well it was pretty close so uh
all your breakers all your roomies that
voted for jessica you better hope she's
right you trash if you voted for her and
she doesn't win you're kicked off the
island wait so if i win this week do i
get the seafood boil no no no no that's
the way the whole season if you win this
week you get a tic tac one tic tac and
it's the white ones that taste awful
second place is a set of steak knives
third place is you're fired you're fired
you laughing now you can't finish that
line uh
uh but yes thank you for tuning in today
tune in every day this week watch g-hunt
today because tomorrow we're not gonna
be spoiler free no we're not gonna be
talking
you got a few hours in your day you
don't have to stay up late i know you
got kids they're just back to school uh
you got work to do you got things to do
at night don't stay up till midnight
that's crazy why would you do that maybe
if you have time to watch it in the
morning tomorrow watch it then or if you
don't if you don't have time to watch it
till the evening you can watch the break
room later catch up now absolutely if
you're still watching hit that like
button uh and tune in every day this
week here on the break room we love you
we appreciate you all your breakers your
roomies your wonderful people have a
good evening have a good rest of
wednesday man i hate the [ __ ] egos
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you